and welcome back everybody we're
finishing Today's Show Out in Los
Angeles where the fate of former That
70s Show star Danny Masterson is in the
hands of a jury for a second time the
actor is charged with raping three women
at his Hollywood Hills Home in the early
2000s all three women are former members
of the Church of Scientology Masterson
had been a Scientologist for much of his
life he was initially tried on the
charges last fall but the jury couldn't
reach a unanimous decision but it was
revealed that more of the jurors favored
acquittal than a guilty verdict his
retrial started in April with the
prosecution getting the green light to
bring in additional evidence they argued
that Masterson drugged his victims
before raping them all three women
testified about their alleged assaults
for a second time they mentioned
becoming unusually groggy and having
gaps of Consciousness after consuming
drinks that were made by Masterson
Masterson's attorney Philip Cohen made
it known that the charges are not
related to drugging the women and no
forensic proof of drugging was shown in
court Cohen said he doesn't believe
there's a grand conspiracy but rather
that the victim's stories could have
been tweaked the alleged victims have
pending civil lawsuits against Masterson
as well as the Church of Scientology
Thursday marked the second day of
deliberations in the case Masterson
faces up to 40 years in prison if
convicted on all three counts so Terry
the judge didn't allow certain evidence
in in the first trial but is allowing
the same evidence in in the second trial
what's the justification for doing that
well it's hard to see what the
justification is in the first trial the
judge did not allow evidence of drug use
he did say that the victims could
testify about how they felt but they
could only testify about that and
nothing else no testimony came in
because drug use and Drug adherence was
not something that was being charged in
that case the second issue with
Scientology the judge didn't allow any
experts to testify about scientology in
the first case in the second case the
judge said you can introduce an expert
and that expert can talk about whether
or not the this Scientology had anything
to do with the women and why they didn't
bring it up at first and the policies
under that particular religion and so
the judge said she thought it was
relevant as it related to consent or use
of force so none of the facts have
changed and none of the law has changed
and yet the judge is allowing this
information and this evidence to get in
you have to wonder why she's changing
her mind during the second trial when
nothing in the case has changed except
her decision
well Brian if Masterson is convicted
what happens then so Jesse I'm a little
Jesse I'm a far more jaded than Terry
when it comes to this because the public
defender in me says I know exactly what
changed the judge saw that a conviction
wasn't going to happen because to your
point they were leaning towards a quit
the numbers were 10 to 2 8 to 4 and 7-5
in favor of acquitting so now these two
fundamental things are changed and
Masterson is convicted I think the
defense has a very strong argument to
say when this evidence didn't come in
looks like my client was about to get
acquitted or at least close to that when
the judge allowed us to come in without
any real justification for changing it
this information biased my client it
shouldn't have come in it didn't come in
the first time and now he's convicted so
what's the major difference here I think
it makes for a great appellate argument
if he's convicted and maybe they win
that's a good interesting legal argument
we'll see if it gets there
and welcome back everybody Tiger Woods
is back in the news for developments off
the golf course the multi-million dollar
claims filed by his former girlfriend
Erica Herman have been tossed out of
court by a Florida judge Herman accused
the golf Superstar of sexual harassment
and asked the court to throw out a 2017
non-disclosure agreement under the Speak
Out act she also challenged the validity
of the NDA itself this followed a
previous lawsuit against Woods trust
claiming a violation of an oral
agreement between the couple that
agreement allegedly let her live in
Woods's Florida home rent free for
another five years in exchange for quote
valuable Services she says that Woods
instead tricked her into going to the
airport so he could lock her out of his
Florida State for good the release of
the NDA was part of hermann's strategy
to keep both litigations in a Florida
courtroom but the judge didn't buy her
sexual harassment claims calling them
quote vague and threadbare because
Herman failed to provide any factual
basis for them the judge also considered
the NDA to be valid at face value the
judge ultimately ruled that Herman must
adhere to the agreement and all matters
have to be taken up by an arbitrator
instead of the court system so Brian we
know it's a big win for Tiger Woods but
how big of a win is it because could he
still lose an arbitration let me put it
this way Jesse it's like he's 200 par so
it's like an eagle and here are the two
points one if the NBA still exists then
more likely than not there are terms
within that NDA as to how this case
needs to be litigated through
arbitration oftentimes a person who
writes the NDA gets the better benefit
of it because they get the benefit of
how the NDA works the way a person gets
the money and Tiger Woods would just pay
her off to make it work the way that he
wants it to the second part that puts us
under par it's not on the spotlight
Tiger Woods doesn't want to air out his
dirty laundry so keeping the secret and
following the rules that he put out
there makes it way better now she comes
back with actual sexual allegations
could be a bogey for him you want a
little golf clap for that for all those
puns but Terry I'm gonna go to video the
court said that the sexual harassment
claim lacked specificity what type of
details should Herman have alleged well
you actually have
the details in an allegation like that
so sexual harassment is any unwanted
action against somebody and it has to be
either really persistent or it has to be
offensive and it has to interfere with
their work environment she's claiming
she was working for him now I think you
have to really wonder whether or not
this was a work environment or whether
or not it was just some sort of living
Arrangement it is very unclear to me
based on what they're saying she should
have had the dates the time the places
she should have had exactly what he did
how many times he did it and so that's
the specificity the court was looking
for and that's why the court said no
this is too vague it is very threadbare
and it is dismissed well for Tiger Woods
it's a big win on a legal front and a PR
front we do have some unique crime news
for you right now the man accused of
stealing a pair of the ruby slippers
that were worn in The Wizard of Oz is
officially facing charges that's right
Terry John Martin was federally indicted
this week accused of taking the shoes
from the Judy Garland Museum in
Minnesota almost 20 years ago the shoes
estimated to be more worth more than
three million dollars were recovered
during a sting operation in 2018 but the
feds had it named a suspect until now
Martin was indicted on one count of
theft of a major artwork Garland wore
several pairs of ruby slippers when
filming the movie in the 1930s and only
four pairs are known to still exist
including the ones that were stolen in
2005. since the shoes were recovered
they have been in federal custody as
evidence Judy Garland fans are hoping
they can go up for display once again
when the case is closed and some good
news out of Texas on Monday officers in
Fort Worth responded to a call about a
kidnapping a woman said a random man
jumped into her car and drove off with
her six-month-old inside a search
started in just about an hour later
officers found the car and arrested the
suspect but there was no baby body cam
video shows the moment that officers
spotted the child in his car seat safe
hey
we have the baby
oh
it's okay it's okay
it's okay
now that is a great ending